250000 c'est le nombre de doses du
vaccin astrazeneca bloqué par l'italie
ce vendredi à l'issue d'une rencontre
avec la france le pays a justifié sa
décision
les laboratoires pharmaceutiques sont en
retard dans l'approvisionnement qu'ils
ont garanti à l'union européenne
toute l'europe est actuellement touchée
par le variant anglais et s'inquiète du
nombre croissant d'infections et c'est
pour cette raison que nous avons décidé
en coordination avec les institutions de
l'union européenne de ne pas autoriser
l'exportation des 250 mille doses ce
n'est pas un acte hostile envers
l'australie nous avons simplement
appliquer un règlement européen approuvé
le 30 janvier un mécanisme qui prévoient
de bloquer les exportations de vaccins
vers les pays qui sont les moins
vulnérables aux qu'ovide canberra a
exprimé sa compréhension
en tenant compte de l'évolution de la
pandémie en europe ce vendredi
l'australie compte et seulement 14
nouveaux cas confirmés contre 24 milles
en italie un blocage aussi approuvé par
la commission européenne
notre affaire et de dire qu'une décision
était prise par les autorités italiennes
que nous avons soutenue sur les
exportations car nous estimons que des
progrès doivent être faits dans la
livraison au pays lieu c'est
essentiellement la conversation que nous
continuerons d'avoir avec l'entreprise
qui produit astrazeneca astrazeneca
annoncé en janvier ne pouvoir livrer au
premier trimestre car tiers des 120
millions de doses initialement promis
aux européens
des retards de livraison dont pâtit
aussi la france je comprend l'italie la
france pourrait faire la même chose
la france est habilité à discuter avec
ses partenaires européens en vue de
faire en sorte que les laboratoires
respectent leur engagement et leur
contrat la commission européenne
rappelle que cette décision est
exceptionnelle et que le lieu reste un
grand exportateur de vaccins